[Music]
[Applause]
Make Way for Mike Florio the popular
co-host of pro football talk live he
also has a new book coming out father of
mine it's next Tuesday and uh it's only
uh 4.99 Mike is he's a best-selling
author of course you know we had
Playmakers now I think he's uh he's
branching out here what what's the theme
of Father of Mine here Mike mob novel
set back in 1973 Dan and the setting is
the town I grew up in 60 miles from
Pittsburgh where the mob was prevalent
my dad was actually a bookie who was
connected to the Mob but I will say this
there have been no emeritas violated in
the crafting of this piece I do not want
to end up sleeping with the fishes or
anything else that may be sleeping at
the bottom of a body of water so I think
I'm covered there what do you think
everybody who was involved is dead dead
now so I won't be hopefully what did you
see growing up
I saw some wild stuff and I didn't think
anything of it because it was normal to
me my dad had a bar and I would go in
there from time to time meet the
different guys they're always nice to
you right nine ten years old you're a
little kid but
there were other places I'd go with my
dad and just that that mystery that
smell the beer and the cigarettes and
you're walking among the bar stools
Bruce Springsteen explains it in his in
his autobiography going into the world
of men when you're a little kid he used
to have to go fetch his dad from the bar
and that's kind of what it was like but
as I got older and I would see newspaper
accounts of what some of these guys that
I used to see all the time allegedly are
actually dead that's an eye-opener so
especially as I wrote this I did some
research about what that crew actually
or allegedly did back in the day and
it's like man there's some bad dudes
that I probably would have run the other
direction if I had only known back when
I was eight nine ten years old what they
were capable of people get murdered
oh yeah allegedly or actually or
otherwise well so all right so that's
next Tuesday florio's book father of
mine and uh only 4.99 available wherever
uh you get your books okay a few things
to talk to you about Ian Rappaport had a
tweet saying that the Niners are
Fielding calls for Trey Lance
what is the market for Trey Lance and
what would it cost to get treylands
first of all when a report is made that
a team is Fielding calls we know it's
coming from the team the team wants it
out there and sometimes the truth is
that the team is actually making the
calls but they are very careful to tell
the reporter it's Fielding because you
give up any leverage you have if you
look desperate that you're making these
calls but Dan it's obvious the ship has
sailed Trey Lance isn't the guy Brock
Purdy is and the moment he's healthy
he's the starter and I feel like Trey
Lance if he's there in San Francisco is
going to be competing with Sam darnold
for number two not Purdy for number one
so the market ultimately is what it is
but the 49ers learned the hard way they
were a little too stubborn with what
they wanted for Jimmy Garoppolo they
kept their thumb on the scale they
ultimately weren't able to trade him now
it worked out because they needed him
when Trey Lance broke his ankle but I I
think that what they need to do is see
what happens first couple rounds of the
draft see where the quarterbacks go or
don't go and I don't know do you get a
second rounder next year do you get
something conditional based on whether
he plays how much he plays some sort of
a formula like what the
Jets and Packers are trying to work out
for Aaron Rodgers but I don't think it's
much and they're going to push the idea
they're going to try to save some face
and they may end up not being able to
get a deal done if they want more than
what anyone is willing to give because
what do you give for a guy who has
played very little football Dan in the
last three years 2020 pandemic
restricted the North Dakota State season
just like a couple of games didn't play
in 21. hardly played in 22. what are you
getting in a guy who's still fairly
young but who hasn't played much
football in three years you mentioned
Aaron Rodgers in the Jets and I don't
know if if we're on the same page but it
feels like it might be day two of the
draft can can the can the Jets hold off
giving the first round pick this year
and then say we'll give you a second
round pick this year and then a first
round next year to the Packers and then
this is completed I think the only thing
they agree on for now Dan is that the
pick this year would be one of the two
second rounders the Jets currently have
back to back from the Elijah Moore trade
to Cleveland they've got back to back
picks I think 43 and 44. and the
question is what do the Packers get in
2024 what do the Jets get in 2025 if
Aaron Rodgers were to retire after only
one season I think that's part of this
equation as well and because we're so
close to the second day of the draft now
there's no reason for either side to
move to their bottom line now they wait
until the last minute the plane lands
they find a way to make their two
positions meet and I've said the over
under is six o'clock Eastern Friday the
28th there's a chance they get it worked
out late afternoon just to be done
there's also a chance it happens when
the pick in round two that's going to
the Packers is actually on the clock
that if the trade occurs during round
two of the draft okay so we're on the
same page that this first round pick for
the Jets is not going to Green Bay not
going to Green Bay okay but it'll be the
the second round pick or maybe a couple
of picks but there has to be some kind
of conditional language in here as you
mentioned with Rogers because like I'd
still have trepidation if I'm the judge
this is a guy who said he was 90 percent
retired before he went into the dark
hole
and now you're going to give up a second
round pick and then a first round pick
or whatever it might be but I'm gonna
guess that kind of language will be in
this transaction
well yes that's what the Jets are trying
to protect themselves against and look
there's a chance that Aaron Rodgers
wasn't telling the truth when he said he
was 90 retired because it's part of this
broader narrative that
I was just gonna walk off into the
sunset I thought the Packers wanted me
back and then I heard that they were
shopping me and that's when everything
changed it makes for a great story
regardless of whether or not it's true
this 90 thing may have just been him
trying to Fashion a greater myth than
what reality would support and the
consequence is it's freaked out the Jets
to the point where they're concerned
he's going to be one and done in New
York and when Tom Brady first joined the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers one of the greatest
business objectives of ownership was
make sure he comes back for another year
make sure he comes back and I think the
Jets will bend over backwards to try to
make sure there's a second year for
Aaron Rodgers and the Jets want that
protection in 25 in the event that
Rogers is one and done and who knows we
didn't expect farv to be one and done
with the Jets and he was
the Demar Hamlin situation he's already
one comeback player of the year if you
come back from Death twice I'm guessing
that you'll be the comeback player of
the year
what kind of language will be in that
Contra is there an addendum to his
contract with the Buffalo Bills with him
coming back I mean how does the team
protect itself
well
I I think that he's cleared he's he's
back and he's playing he's only entering
his third season so it's not even as if
they could do a new contract for
tomorrow Hamlin his existing contract is
still in place the question is once he's
physically cleared mentally what's it
going to be like for him to put his
uniform on and go back out onto a
football field I don't even know how
much he remembers about what happened
maybe there is no PTSD or scarring of
him that he would have to overcome
because
for the rest of us when he walked out on
the field we're gonna we're gonna hold
our breath every time he's involved in a
tackle we're going to wait and make sure
he's okay I just think that's human
nature but
given that it apparently is commodio
quartus this very rare occasion of
getting struck in the chest and your
heart stops and it happens to anybody
and it happens very infrequently it's
not some condition he has it sounds like
he's good to go it really is amazing
that we're less than four months from
the thing happening and he is good to go
clean Bella Health back on the bills and
they go forward but Mike it sounds
strange to say this but I'm more
concerned for tuatanga violoa than I am
Demar Hamlin
I think you're absolutely right to be to
talk about Loa is a guy who is smaller
than most quarterbacks the physics
aren't on his side and what have we seen
we haven't seen him get drilled in the
head by somebody who drops their helmet
and hits a quarterback the way they used
to we see him get shoved to the ground
and what happens when he hits the ground
his helmet strikes the turf and he gets
a concussion it happened at least two
times most of us with common sense
believe it happened three times last
year despite the official claim that it
was a back injury so he's working on
falling the right way he's studying Jiu
Jitsu it's one thing to study it it's
another thing to put it into practice
when you're out on the field that's what
I'd be concerned about I'm concerned
about that for Bryce young he's going to
be under 200 pounds when he plays can he
fall in a way that doesn't result in his
head striking the turf and giving him a
brain injury I'm far more concerned
about two of than I am to marham but
aren't they developing we're talking to
Mike Florio pro football talk
are they developing a new helmet just
for quarterbacks
yeah that's got a greater level of
protection in the back of the helmet so
when that bone hits the ground because
that's what we see the head snaps back
and the bone hits what can they do to
keep the brain from being injured but
you know the bottom line Dan is you can
wear the best helmet in the world but
when your body is moving and suddenly
stops your brain bounces off the inside
there's nothing you can do about the
brain bouncing off the inside of the
skull there's still going to be
concussions in football but you can
reduce the severity of the blow that
comes from the outside any doubts on
Jalen hurts
I don't think so not after what we saw
last year and this contract now I'm
still waiting for the deal to be
officially done once it's done we'll be
able to look at the full details we'll
see what the true commitment is and most
importantly when does the window open on
the Eagles getting out of it if for some
reason he regresses look at what Russell
Wilson did last year or didn't do in
Denver the Broncos would love to be able
to tear that up they can't because of
the way the contract is structured
there's so many clues that come from the
full details that tell us when the
Eagles would be able to say oops got
that wrong we're going to move on but
there's no reason to think he's not
going to get better we saw a Josh Allen
type jump from him last year passing and
running and Leadership and everything
the Eagles have been looking for since
the moment they traded Don of McNabb to
Washington on Easter Sunday of 2010.
they've been searching they've been
hoping they thought it was Carson Wentz
it wasn't Nick Foles maybe it wasn't and
now they have it in Jalen hurts
what's this mean for Lamar Jackson
well damn what I would do right now we
had a breakdown yesterday of the
contract Jalen hurts accepted and the
offer that Lamar Jackson rejected in
August and just some of the data points
and we broke them all down we talked
about it earlier today on PFT live as
well what I would do if I was Lamar
Jackson first and foremost it's hiring
agent second maybe he's not going to do
that I would get Odell Beckham Jr
frankly to try to be the go-between
right now there's a hybrid deal to be
done between the deal that Lamar Jackson
rejected last year and the deal that
Jalen hurts is doing this week where you
can slap the two together and you can
come up with something that works for
Lamar Jackson and Dan at some point
regardless of what anyone thinks about
the whys and what's at play and what
factors are being involved at some point
Lamar Jackson's got to say yes he's got
to say yes to something you have to look
at what's out there it's as good as it's
going to get and you just have to say
yes and continue your career and if you
don't if your career doesn't continue
it's stuck in the mud until you finally
say yes to someone but Mike he would
have already been what two years into
his old contract and then we would be
two years later now you're into a new
contract that's you're always going to
be underpaid a couple of years or a year
after you sign your contract in your
mind right but Dan here's the bottom
line if he had done the deal that Josh
Allen did two years ago they were
drafted the same year
Allen did his contract after three
seasons and I remember when the word
first broke of the Josh Allen contract I
said I want to see that deal because
when we see the details it's either
going to be the player or the team in
Baltimore that wants to take that
contract and make it the contract for a
large accent when I saw that deal I said
Lamar Jackson should take this to the
Ravens and say just cross out the names
change them this is my contract and when
you look at what Josh Allen has got the
last two years and what Lamar Jackson
has got
Josh Allen has made 41 million more than
Lamar Jackson the last two years and
that's never coming back I don't care
what you get paid going forward that 41
million is never coming back those days
are done and over you never get paid for
what you've previously done you only get
paid for the future so already he's 41
million behind Josh Allen and the
question is how much worse is it going
to get the Panthers team GM says that uh
he hasn't told anybody who will be the
number one pick although Bryce young has
canceled all of his other trips
elsewhere which would lead me to believe
uh I think the Draft starts at two
because I don't know if the Texans are
sold on a quarterback here feels like
Bryce young is going number one overall
correct
yeah and it was a great point that our
coordinating producer at PFT Live Matt
Casey texted him while we were talking
about it today because we played the
sound of Scott fitter the GM of the
Panthers talking about what they plan to
do to put weight on Bryce Young and the
way he talked about it when you listen
to it it sounds like it's not a
hypothetical it sounds like this is what
we're gonna do but do you think the
commissioner has said to Carolina just
don't say anything here
Dan I look at it this way if they're not
bashful about calling their broadcast
partners and instructing them to tell
their reporters to keep their mouths
shut about anything they know about who
the picks are going to be they're
probably not Bachelorette okay telling
the teams yeah they want people to tune
in for eight o'clock to 8 20. they don't
want people tuning in for the Texans
pick they want people to be there at
eight o'clock thinking maybe there's a
chance it's not going to be Bryce young
okay what do the Texans do what are the
do you believe the Draft starts at two
oh yeah yeah I mean they could trade out
of that spot obviously they could trade
down for a team that has plenty of needs
you know if you're not talking about
going down many picks and you pick up
some extra significant draft Capital
that goes a long way toward blowing the
fact that they could have had the first
overall pick if they just hadn't beaten
the Colts in the fourth quarter of week
18. yeah so it's either quarterback Edge
rusher or trade down and you got to
consider who their coach is now Demico
Ryan's where'd he come from San
Francisco let's go back to what we
already talked about Ryan's first Year's
defensive coordinator they give up three
ones and a three to get Trey Lance how'd
that work out second year they take a
flyer with the last pick in the draft on
Brock Purdy how'd that work out what do
you think Ryan's wants do you think
Ryan's wants a guy who could be their
Nick Bosa in an edge rusher at number
two or does Ryan's want to put all the
eggs in a quarterback basket and have it
possibly blow up on them so he may be
pushing defensive player to supercharge
that side of the ball and get a
quarterback later or or and I always
Advocate this because in my mind the
draft is a lottery the more lottery
tickets you have the better chance you
have to get players that turn around
especially a bad team trade down if you
can get more picks explain the new
Wonderlic or is it the new Wonderlic the
S2 test for players quarterbacks
well the S2 test as I understand it is
about cognitive ability In the Heat of
the Moment processing information when
you're in that blender of factors you
think about everything a quarterback has
to deal with pre-snap post Snap all the
information about processing recall and
Bryce young did really well on it and
the Panthers are big Believers in it
specifically their owner David Tepper so
this is a way unique to quarterbacks
when you are the one who is standing
there where all that stuff's happening
think about all the variables which
receiver is open who's blitzing can I
trust my running back to pick this guy
up who else is coming around so they're
using that now the Wonderlic is
worthless this to the extent that
there's a dotted line or a bright line
connection helps teams understand how
that guy's going to do when it's time to
stand in there and decide where to throw
the football always great to talk to you
he's Mike Florio in his new book about
his uh father who was a bookie and
probably saw some bad people in in
Pittsburgh
the official title which is called
father of mine not father of mine who
was a bookie who saw bad things happen
with the mob in Pittsburgh a legend
or possibly available next Tuesday
thank you Mike thanks Dan thank you Mike
my bookie was
um
he was known locally in a very
upstanding uh businessman
and uh I remember he drove a Lincoln
Continental a Mark III
it was a blue Mark III
and there's a reason why he drove that
and lived in a real nice house because
bookies make the money